[Música]
y para nosotros es una excelente
oportunidad estar el día de hoy aquí
para poder compartir con ustedes que
este problema de los niños niñas y
adolescentes que no cuentan con el
cuidado de la familia
un problema mundial que debe atender se
requiere de acciones urgentes para poder
garantizar a este grupo de población su
derecho a la salud al bienestar a la
protección a la participación a la
educación y al desarrollo
en la américa latina y en el caribe se
hace un uso indiscriminado de la
internación de estos niños niñas y
adolescentes por protección aun cuando
esta medida debería ser una medida de
último recurso de por un espacio breve
de tiempo está motivada siempre conforme
a la ley y también verificar en todo
momento su necesidad idoneidad y
proporcionalidad
esta medida debe aplicarse cuando las
alternativas de apoyo a la familia han
fracasado y cuando no se cuenta con una
familia extensa a una red familiar como
tíos primos hermanos que puedan asumir
el cuidado de estos niños
existen muy pocos datos al respecto sin
embargo se calcula que en américa latina
y el caribe también en esta región deben
existir alrededor de 240 mil niños niñas
y adolescentes viviendo sin el cuidado
de sus padres y otros miles están en un
grave riesgo de perder este cuidado
debido a la migración a la violencia a
los conflictos armados al pobres a los
desastres naturales entre muchos otros
todos estos países ya han ratificado la
convención de los derechos del niño la
convención desde su preámbulo señala que
el niño para su pleno y armonioso
desarrollo deberá crecer en el seno de
una familia en un ambiente de amor
comprensión y felicidad y aunque también
podemos percibir que algunos de estos
países ya han hecho adecuaciones
importantes en sus legislaciones y en
sus departamentos internos es muy
importante que subrayemos que el número
de niños niñas
en estas instituciones de protección
continúa siendo muy elevado la red
latinoamericana de acogimiento familiar
de la cual nuestra organización forma
parte realizó un estudio que denominó
los olvidados
en hogares en este estudio la relación
busca alertar a todos los países sobre
el uso desmedido de la
institucionalización busca la
erradicación de las macro instituciones
y también busca instar a todos los
países a fortalecer sus políticas de
infancia para que los niños niñas y los
adolescentes puedan permanecer con sus
familias de origen para fines prácticos
la regla de cine a las macro
instituciones como estos enormes
establecimientos donde existe un gran
número de niños
y no están dadas las condiciones para
garantizar sus derechos fundamentales
solamente para tener una idea de la
magnitud de este problema mencionaré
algunos ejemplos en el salvador existe
en la casa en la sagrada familia son de
tres lugares dentro de un mismo
perímetro or cerrado que tienen una
capacidad instalada para 600
beneficiarios y hay una ocupación de 450
niños
en perú en la provincia de lima
encontramos el hogar puericultorio pérez
araníbar este hogar tiene una capacidad
instalada para 800 beneficiarios
de una ocupación de 300 en guatemala
tenemos el hogar solidario en este hogar
se albergan 774 niños de todas las
edades
también en guatemala
el llamado hogar seguro virgen de la
asunción el 8 de marzo de 2017 sucede
una catástrofe incendiaria es muy
importante que les comenté que ya desde
el 2013 se venían recibiendo denuncias
sobre el maltrato físico y los abusos
sexuales que allí ocurrían además de que
se suponía que podía existir una trata
de personas al interior de este centro y
había una ocupación de 800 niños niñas y
adolescentes cuando su capacidad
instalada era solamente para 500 sucede
entonces que este 8 de marzo de 2017 un
grupo de jovencitas se manifestaban por
estos abusos que sufrían que sufrían por
parte de sus cuidadores
la situación se sale de control en 50 y
una de ellas son enterradas en una sala
un pequeño salón de 4x4
la situación se vuelve realmente caótica
cuando se provoca un incendio al
interior de este salón por la quema de
unas colchonetas lamentablemente las
chiquitas no pueden ser rescatadas a
tiempo al 10 de marzo se documentaba ya
que
treinta y siete de ellas habían
fallecido
de los 14 y los dice
y posteriormente se comprobó que algunas
de las sobrevivientes se encontraban
embarazadas
es por ello que desde el 2009 la onu ya
había emitido las directrices para las
morales como realidades alternativas de
cuidado de los niños
estas son pautas muy concretas que
dictan el accionar de todos aquellos que
se encarguen de la atención de niños
niñas y adolescentes que están privados
del cuidado de esos
en relación al tamaño de las
instituciones la directriz 123 señala
los centros de acogimiento residencial
deberán ser los más pequeños posibles
estar organizados en razón de los
derechos y necesidades de los niños que
allí se alberguen además
se deberá trabajar activamente por
reintegrar a estos niños ya sus familias
y establecer programas dentro de esta
dinámica que se busquen sea lo más
parecido al la dinámica que se presenta
en las familias o en los grupos
reducidos
pero cuál es la situación de nuestro
país
recordemos que los principales garantes
de los derechos de los niños son los
padres a falta de los padres
al día de hoy en nuestro país no tenemos
un ser insuficiente ni un sistema de
información que arroje datos fidedignos
sobre el número de niños niñas y
adolescentes viviendo en estas
instituciones aquí la pregunta sería si
no sabemos quiénes son en dónde están y
en qué condiciones viven cómo podremos
ofrecer un seguimiento cercano y una
supervisión adecuada a cada uno de los
casos
desde el 2006
la observación número 37 del comité de
los derechos del niño a nuestro país
donde la onu señala la preocupación por
esta situación en méxico que recomienda
a nuestro país que se tomen medidas
urgentes para poder determinar el número
de niños institucionalizados y las
condiciones en las que ellos viven
un excelente amigo psicólogo y
colaborador con el que he compartido
muchos años de trabajo conjunto en esta
causa gaudí rodríguez él escribió un
ensayo que denominó encerrados
este ensayo es un documento ampliamente
recomendable ya que es un documento que
de manera muy sensible plasma la
realidad de estos niños niñas y
adolescentes en nuestro país además este
ensayo gana una mención especial en el
concurso genéricos inicial de 2013 del
poder federal
del poder judicial de la federación
en este ensayo gaudí subraya afirmó que
el izquierdo excluye a los niños de la
sociedad su acceso a la justicia queda
obstaculizado entre las paredes otro
punto fundamental que debemos tocar
dentro del contexto de esta problemática
son las evidencias científicas
en relación a las graves afectaciones
que sufren este grupo de población
debido a los largos periodos de
institucionalización que ellos viven les
comento como un dato que nosotros
tenemos tres chicos ahora que están
iniciando la universidad y todos
llegaron a nuestro centro entre los 6 y
los 7
su vida transcurre dentro de las paredes
de las
las evidencias científicas que podemos
nosotros comentarles a ustedes son
muchas que han quedado documentadas por
diversos miembros de la comunidad
científica como burning speech winnicott
freud y el doctor volví
en 1948 ya desde 1948 la onu estaba
preocupada por esta situación y decidió
hacer una investigación sobre todos
aquellos niños que viven
y gas
esta tarea es encomendada al doctor jon
volví de inicio en 1950 y de ahí se
desprende del informe cuidado maternal y
salud mental
el estudio quedó plenamente comprobado
las afectaciones emocionales que sufren
estos niños los transtornos los síntomas
de trastornos emocionales y mentales que
se presentan así como un franco retraso
en el desarrollo físico intelectual y
social por la ausencia del cuidado de
sus madres
un trastorno una afectación que es muy
significativa es la incapacidad que
tienen estos niños niñas de poder
establecer
lazos afectivos profundos y duraderos
debido a la ausencia de
el doctor volví le denominó a esto
carácter
también hay afectaciones en los procesos
intelectuales los cuales se presentan
con mayor frecuencia en el área del
lenguaje y en la capacidad de
abstracción en las siguientes décadas se
continuó estudiando estas afectaciones y
quedaron también documentadas
más más trastornos que se presentan
debido a las separaciones tempranas y a
los largos procesos de
institucionalización tales como
trastornos de mi sueño
en racing anorexia sensación de profundo
rechazo y soledad
algo muy significativo también que vemos
nosotros con mucha frecuencia una
incapacidad para adaptarse al medio
escolar trastornos en el comportamiento
y una tendencia a establecer relaciones
interpersonales
llegan a ser ves organizadas y
disruptivas se ha documentado también
los trastornos en el desarrollo
cognitivo está comprobado que en los
niños y en las niñas menores de 3 años
que sufren largos periodos de
institucionalización se pueden presentar
alteraciones en el desarrollo neuronal
que es crucial por el crecimiento del
cerebro que puede desembocar incluso en
una disminución de su perímetro craneal
pero bueno ante este escenario existen
algunas alternativas para estos niños
niñas y adolescentes afortunadamente si
organismos internacionales nacionales
gubernamentales
[Música]
así como de la sociedad civil ya ha
realizado recomendaciones muy puntuales
que nos llevan a un cambio de paradigma
para poder transitar en la atención a
ellos desde un enfoque de necesidades a
un verdadero enfoque de derechos las
primeras recomendaciones las encontramos
en el informe mundial de violencia
contra niños y niñas desde el 2006 aquí
desde el 2006 ya se está insistiendo
sobre los efectos nocivos de la
institucionalización otro muy importante
otra recomendación muy importante es el
llamado a la acción el llamado a la
acción es un movimiento que se hunde que
surge por iniciativa de las reglas que
es la red latinoamericana de acogimiento
familiar por la unicef por el movimiento
mundial
para la infancia de américa latina y el
caribe así como por la secretaria
especial del secretario general de la
onu contra violencia para los niños la
finalidad de este llamado a la acción es
erradicar la internación
menores de tres años en instituciones ya
que son como mencioné anteriormente los
más susceptibles a sufrir estos efectos
los amigos aquí debemos mencionar tres
datos que son sumamente preocupantes por
cada año
chiquito menor o una chiquita menor de 3
años pasa en una institución pierde 4
meses de desarrollo
la violencia es seis veces más frecuente
en las instituciones que en los hogares
de acogida y la violencia sexual también
es seis veces más frecuente
las instituciones que en los cuidados
alternativos que se basan en familias
otra recomendación muy importante puede
ser implementar las directrices
de la onu en todos los programas y en
todas las acciones que se realicen a
favor de este grupo de población
contamos también en mexico ya desde el
2014 con la ley general de derechos de
niños niñas y adolescentes
y también con el primer instrumento
nacional de política pública denominado
25 al 25 son 25 objetivos nacionales
que deberá cumplirse al 2025 y nosotros
queda mucho tiempo para ello con la
finalidad de garantizar los derechos que
en méxico ha reconocido a sus niños las
niñas y sus adolescentes también desde
la sociedad civil les podemos compartir
que nosotros hemos conformado ya la red
nacional por el derecho a vivir en
familia de niños niñas y adolescentes y
en guanajuato tendremos
en marzo del 2020 un seminario
internacional conjuntamente con la regla
y la procuraduría de derechos humanos de
guanajuato que hemos denominado poniendo
fin al encierro de niños y niñas y
adolescentes en méxico en el contexto
internacional
concluía yo esta charla
con una reflexión que me parece muy
atinada y que está incluida en el ensayo
encerrados
las organizaciones de protección podemos
cubrir de manera adecuada las
necesidades fisiológicas de que los
niños requieren para su sobrevivencia
resguardo alimentación atención médica y
psicológica lo que las organizaciones no
podemos cubrir son las necesidades de
afiliación de reconocimiento de
autorrealización nos referimos a las más
elevadas en la escala de necesidades
humanas
afectó la seguridad la confianza la
identidad el sentido de pertenencia
de verdad que integrar a estos niños
niños y adolescentes
en nuestra comunidad y en sus familias
es una tarea enorme pero pensamos que es
la sociedad la que debe comprometerse
porque será toda la sociedad la que se
verá beneficiada son somos capaces de
reconocer las diferencias y podemos dar
a cada uno de estos niños niñas y
adolescentes los elementos que requiere
para su pleno desarrollo personal
la invitación sería entonces para que
trabajemos juntos y todos logremos más
familias a sus vidas
[Aplausos]